[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal de
cette suite voici les titres de ce jeudi
18 mai nommé ce mercredi 17 mai gérard
collomb a réservé son premier
déplacement de nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur au commissariat de trappes
celui qui était jusqu'à présent sénateur
maire de lyon souhaite réconcilier la
population et la police
la fédération la fédération du bâtiment
des yvelines organisait hier 17 mai un
débat avec plusieurs candidats aux
législatives d'autres départements
le secteur du btp qui représente 50
mille entreprises peut être entendu et
pour cela il a rédigé son 12
propositions d attendre désormais des
réponses enfin des agents de la
direction départementale du travail de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en grève
aujourd'hui à l'initiative de plusieurs
syndicats
ils protestent contre la suppression de
postes dans la région
bonsoir on commence par de la politique
nommé ministre de l'intérieur et hier
après midi à 15 heures le nouveau
ministre gérard collomb s'est rendu au
commissariat de trappes en fin de
journée à 19h pour son tout premier
déplacement officiel avec son nouveau
statut
il est notamment revenu sur les affaires
de délinquance dans la commune un
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
gérard collomb n'a pas perdu tant quatre
heures après avoir été nommé ministre de
l'intérieur l'homme politique est venu
au commissariat de trappes pour son tout
premier déplacement officiel
objectif rencontrer les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain il a également
évoqué avec eux la sphère malik du nom
de cet homme soupçonné d'assassinât et
de tentatives d'assassinats plaisir et
attrapes
je pense que c'est quelque chose
évidemment dramatique qui est
extrêmement grave et plutôt que d'aller
visiter des lieux vous effectivement il
n'y a pas de difficultés
j'ai souhaité venir ici pour me faire
expliquer la problématique ce que font
les enquêteurs
et comment on va arrêter le plus vite
possible ce criminel
gérard collomb a été accueillie par le
maire socialiste de la commune guy
malandain deux hommes qui se sont
côtoyés sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale
il ya une un plaisir humains dans la
rencontre après que le missionnaire et
choisi de venir ici je le prends comme
une préoccupation par rapport à un
évènement familial qui s'est passé un
qui n'est pas un événement de la ville
pour l'accueillir également une dizaine
de militants de la république en marche
pour eux cette visite de 20 minutes est
un signe fort envoyé par le nouveau
gouvernement
tout ce travail comme disait le
président dès sa nomination il est venu
à trappes pour nous soutenir c'est très
bien au moins voilà tu n'y as pas parole
là on va la direccte là ça c'est très
bien moi je trouve gérard collomb a
ensuite poursuivi sa visite dans les
yvelines par une rencontre avec les
gendarmes de saint germain en laye et
des pompiers à chanteloup-les-vignes
plusieurs candidats à la législature
dans les yvelines étaient invités à
plancher sur la question du bâtiment ce
mercredi 17 mai à trappes à l'initiative
de l'ancienne de l'antenne pardon local
de la fédération française du bâtiment
le btp a rédigé près de 112 propositions
et souhaitait écoutez les réactions des
candidats à trappes
reportage stéphane servant après la
présentation des 112 proposition du btp
les candidats présents avaient à chaque
fois un temps pour répondre et faire
leurs propositions aux professionnels du
bâtiment devant un public attentif
ils ont les uns après les autres exposer
leurs idées et fait part de leur soutien
un secteur important de l'économie
locale
le bâtiment représente en effet
cinquante mille entreprises mais aussi
15 mille pme et 35000 art
ils ont dans leur quotidien les artisans
et chefs d'entreprises du bâtiment
souhaitent avant tout qu'on leur
simplifie la vie et il semble avoir été
entendu par les candidats principale
demande le besoin de simplification
administrative réponses des candidats
aujourd'hui pour réaliser un chantier
toutes les autorisations en amont et
toutes les contraintes pour réaliser
sont tels que on démobilise je dirais
les entreprises la concertation et la
simplification pour les entreprises du
bâtiment me paraît être un point très
important déjà alors c'est pas les seuls
parce qu'il ya en même temps tout ce qui
concerne la formation est aussi
l'apprentissage s'est créé un guichet
unique pour les formalités
administratives pour toutes les tpe pme
qui sont très nombreuses dans le secteur
du bâtiment de la crainte aussi exprimé
à l'heure du débat sur les travailleurs
détachés par le développement d'une
économie à deux vitesses
fondée sur le dumping social et la
précarisation de l'emploi
un débat de très bonne tenue où l'on a
regretté l'absence du candidat de la
république en marche
une quarantaine de personnes était ce
midi réunis devant les locaux yvelinois
de la direction régionale du travail à
l'appel de plusieurs syndicats ces
agents dépendant du ministère du travail
manifestaient pour s'opposer à la
suppression prévue de plusieurs postes
sur l'ensemble de la région les
précisions avec ce reportage de nicolas
tirer le betis tracts à la main
autocollant sur la veste ses membres de
la cgt essaie tant bien que mal
d'interpeller les passants près de la
gare de montigny le bretonneux
le service public c'est le bien de ceux
qui n'ont pas de bien rassembler devant
l'union départementale de la direction
du travail
il dénonce l'austérité qui touche leur
ministère presque 2000 postes supprimés
en france depuis 2009 285 en ile de
france et bientôt quatre supplémentaires
sur le département des yvelines
les agents de contrôle qui contrôle un
secteur géographique donné le secteur
vous entendra tout point s'agrandir
du coup les agents devons pouvoir rendre
service public de qualité aux usagers
puisque aura de plus en plus de travail
on nous demande de faire quand même le
travail qu'on faisait avant avec 20% des
effectifs allemands en dix ans et à un
moment donné on ne peut plus fonctionner
être décidé avant la présidentielle ce
mouvement était prévue aujourd'hui sur
l'ensemble des régions la récente
victoire d'emmanuel macron ne semble pas
les rassurer le nouveau président
prévoit de réformer rapidement le code
du travail qui dit réforme et diminution
du code du travail dit forcément pour
nous agents chargés du contrôle de ce
code plus de difficultés et plus de
problèmes à venir
contacté par nos soins la direction
régionale du travail n'a pas donné pour
l'instant de réponse à nos
sollicitations et les ont couru pour les
autres près de 350 collégiens et
primaire de maurepas ont multiplié les
kilomètres pour récolter des fonds
les bénéfices sont destinés à
l'association action contre la faim est
un projet en ethiopie retour sur cette
heure de course avec meloni poquet et
mélinda correia ils partent pour une
heure de course
une boucle d'un kilomètre contre la faim
pour les 6e et 5e du collège alexandre
dumas de maurepas ils ont une heure de
sensibilisation par des bénévoles de
l'action de l'association action contre
la faim
donc tous les élèves ont eu une heure de
sensibilisation sur ce que c'était que
l'action contre la faim la notion d'eau
potable dans ces pays des fables souvent
en voie développement défavorisés
paieront 5 tours 8 ou plus certains
cours près de dix kilomètres des
distances échanger contre des dons de
sponsors qu'ils ont eux mêmes trouver
cette année les fonds partiront en
ethiopie avec des gens de notre âge qui
lui vit pas comme lui
d'abord même si je veux pas bénéficié de
ma nourriture de boisson comme on mange
on en voit tous les jours et donc moi ça
me tenait à coeur d'y courir pour eux
quand on pense que c'est pour la bonne
cause
quand ton âme afin sais pas c'est moi
que d'habitude c'est moins douloureux
le collège alexandre dumas participent à
cette course nationale depuis plus de
dix ans l'an passé les élèves avaient
récolté près de 5000 euros
un mot de culture à présent ce week-end
c'est la 13e édition de la nuit des
musées
toute une soirée pour découvrir
autrement les musées la culture
l'histoire notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs mélanie paquet
vous fait un point avec nous sur cette
programmation fait alors ce sont des
choix non exhaustive bien sûr l'or pour
le premier rendez-vous direction le
musée de la ville ouvre à nouveau ses
portes ce samedi 20 mai c'est l'occasion
de fêter ses 40 ans et de découvrir ses
nouveaux locaux parce que pour rappel il
a déménagé se trouve maintenant au rez
de chaussée de la médiathèque
alors le thème cette année le vintage
c'est en lien avec l'exposition
temporaire et ça va passer aussi par le
rétro gaming comprenait le fait de
collectionner et de jouer à d'anciens
jeux vidéo les traditionnels sega
amstrad va toutes ces consoles là qui
ont marqué bien des générations d jeu
pacman super mario bros des jeux bien
sûr qu'ils sont anti qu il est que tout
je connais même s'il n'ya pas jouer
forcément notamment les plus jeunes
générations sous leurs formes anciennes
il y aura un tournoi également
multijoueur et le tournoi ce sera sur
saturn bomberman donc un jeu vidéo
des années 1990 toujours à saint quentin
en yvelines
on peut également aller visiter l'abbaye
de port royal des champs tout à fait
l'abbaye sera en visite libre toute la
soirée avec une ouverture exceptionnelle
celle de l'oratoire qui accueillait à
l'origine le premier musée et les
vitraux seront éclairés et à partir de
20 heures vous pourrez assister à un
concert promenade le thème retour sur la
musique des xviie et xviiie siècles avec
violoncelle et clavecin et troisième et
dernier rendez-vous une visite insolite
à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines vous pourrez
visiter un lieu dans le noir c'est la
maison triolet aragon qui le proposent
les visites seront guidées
c'est une manière inédite de découvrir
la maison des célèbres auteurs et poètes
alors les premières visites débutent à
19h30 et de nombreux autres événements
sont proposés dans les ive et notamment
l'incontournable cité royale versailles
alors pour en découvrir un peu plus sur
toute la programmation le site officiel
du ministère de la culture s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
merci mélanie pour toutes ces idées de
sorties guyancourt pardon aux cultures
encore et encore mais les artistes à
l'honneur jusqu'au 28 mai avec la
nouvelle édition d'art talent un
concours d'arts visuels qui présente une
sélection d'oeuvres de différentes
techniques de la peinture de la
photographie en passant par la sculpture
ou le dessin parmi les artistes
présentés claude champy invité d'honneur
de cette deuxième édition il nous a
parlé de son travail au micro de nicolas
d'andry tout mon travail est cuit en
grande partie à un agrément du boxant
dans des fours à bois je cuis à 1302 est
chez lui
j'ai pas envie de mettre un titre plus
que pour moi c'est une façon d'obliger
les gens à vama certain regard l'office
est mal je parle du jeu j'aime suivante
les gens voient douche
autre chose le voisin c'est la fin de ce
cette fuite le journal merci nous avoir
suivi tous nos reportages sont à
retrouver sur tv fil 78 points com ou
sur l'application tv fil 78 bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]